là on a le premier smartphone iliad qui
viennent la marque brouillonne j'en ai
déjà parlé
l'âge très content parce que khroma pour
la première fois dans un gérant bien
qu'avec
[Musique]
la vidéo d'aujourd'hui est sponsorisé
par wonder cher cependant tant leur
logiciel est très intéressant et juste
après je vous parle bien évidemment du
royaume flex paye est beaucoup plus de
choses à vegas aujourd'hui je vous
parlais d'une solution qui est très
pratique d'un logiciel hyper pratique
pour créer modifier et exporter vos pdf
extrêmement facilement pour ma part j'ai
vraiment souvent galéré pour créer des
pdf
comment les créer comment les exporter
et surtout une fois bout de pdf et déjà
créé comment le modifier il existe bien
quelques outils pour le faire mais pdf
lemon straw coup vraiment le meilleur de
toutes les fonctionnalités en un seul et
même logiciel
et ça croyez moi c'est franchement très
pratique vous pouvez créer des pdf à
partir de fichiers textes fichier excel
à partir d' images à partir de plaintes
formats différents
laissez-moi vous montrer comment ça
marche voilà le logiciel alors vous avez
plusieurs options options principales
vous pouvez modifier un pdf vous pouvez
créer un pdf le créé à partir de pages
html à partir d'imagés à partir d'autres
clichés au format texte pouvait faire
aussi du traitement par l'ons vous
pouvez modifier un formulaire pdf
convertir un pdf déjà existants au
format excel word powerpoint etc
ça c'est super cool et vous pouvez aussi
combiner des pdf créer un seul pdf en
combinant plusieurs types de fichiers
différents
cette solution est vraiment polyvalente
c'est très facile de créer éditer et
asticoter vos pdf de tous les côtés ont
fait exactement ce qu'on veut et ça
simplifie concrètement elle la gestion
de vos fichiers pdf
je vous montre en premier exemple je
veux créer un fichier pdf à partir d'une
image je clique ici je vais ouvrir le
dernier télé loisirs dans lequel ge à
paris bon je vous passe le côté mise en
page vous faire vraiment beaucoup de
choses à ajouter des images du texte
recadrés philippe amagou et faire tout
ce que vous voulez une fois vous avez
fait tout votre travail là dessus
vous allez donc fichiers vous
enregistrer directement en pdf vous
allez dans vos documents vous retrouvez
votre fichier pdf là franchement c'est
hyper cool autre exemple pratique j'ai
déjà un pdf et je veux le modifier
j'avais donc m'ouvrir un pdf là par
exemple j'ai le règlement d'un concours
l'ajax et à tous mon texte que je peux
modifier très très très très très
facilement modalités participation je
viens et je modifie avec un e c'est
mieux voilà et voyez c'est hyper simple
de la même manière on suit je vais là
j'enregistre et ça va me réenregistre
directement mon pdf donc ça c'est
franchement hyper cool là je vous ai
pourtant quelques fonctionnalités de
base mais vous pouvez réellement faire
ce que vous voulez la manière dont vous
le voulez et ça franchement c'est hyper
pratique si vous voulez vous aussi
amélioré complètement la gestion de vos
pdf et franchement vous en ai peut-être
une épine du pied et vous faciliter la
vie vous aimez le lien en bas dans la
description pourrez le découvrir
pdf et mat
a deuxième jour du cms comme je le fais
habituellement je voudrais faire un
petit tour de ma chambre pour vous
montrer un peu ma chambre d'hôtel j'aime
bien partager ces petits moments
privilégiés avec vous commençons par le
commencement
là vous avez la porte c'est pas assez
grand là vous avez un petit côté cause
du salon alors pour julia raciste parce
qu'on avait gas c'est quand même assez
sale franchement c'est un tout qui a
déjà vécu il ya quelques petites tâches
bon on est un peu dans juin cessez le
feu
c'est dégueulasse c'est l'expérience
mais c'est assez normal la télé alors
ici vous avez une cuisine ne suis pas
très bonne cuisine parce qu elles pas
des vieillards rien mais c'est plutôt un
espace je dirais de restauration qu'un
petit bard et peut se poser vous avez
ici le réfrigérateur avec juste pour moi
une seule petite bouteille au monde 10 h
du matin forcément qu'il est forcément
le matin donc là vous avez ma petite
chambre
mais c'est quand même ça donne ce côté
extérieur c'est assez sympa des petits
rangements sécurité mignon comme tout
donc là vous avez le l'entrée de la
salle de bain voilà donc là on peut vous
laver les mains un petit évier là on est
directement dans la chambre voyait mais
bon c'est quand même très très pratique
donc là vous avez la salle de bain avec
des petits wc une petite baignoire voilà
c'est la douche vraiment à l'américain
[Musique]
ok bon bah y'a plus qu'à les semaines
le petit hôtel très cosy avec une petite
cour intérieure
[Musique]
je suis à peine je pense cinq minutes à
pied du csc franchement super
stratégique
l'année dernière j'étais à 45 minutes en
bus ça me semble vraiment la vie on nous
voulons saluer cela sur le stand de
rougeole on dirait sorti le premier
smartphone à écran pliable de nous
prendre en main c'est juste complètement
hallucinant là on a le premier
smartphone
iliad il est là marc oriol j'en ai déjà
parlé et l'âge très content parce que de
deux points pour la première fois donc
je dire en direct avec vous allez c'est
assez marrant l'expérience problème
on n'a qu'à mieux
sensation de solidité avec marc
très surprenant
c'est très longtemps que tous parlent de
smartphones croupillac et la concussion
alors
c'est une version qui est fait pour
l'instant pour les développeurs
qui n'est pas encore commercialisée en
fait j'ai juste à le prendre là il est
dans ce mode là je le retourne
j'attends tranquillement voilà une
semaine dans un autre mode là vous avez
un haut parleur là un autre haut
parleurs là son côté a priori paris si
vous avez le ferons lorsque vous le
faire mais comme ça
on est où le métal oreilles et vous
passez en mode téléphone alors ça c'est
bizarre parce que au final le truc est
quand même assez épais c'est assez mal
si on va pas se mentir
mais sur le principe pourquoi pas
serrières sympa vous avez quoi double
module photo juste là un village et
surtout ce qui est assez intéressante au
niveau de la charnière
du coup on peut le mettre comme ça en
mode paysage je peux peuple
l'avis des directement là on sent là on
sent un petit peu le petit charnière
c'est un petit relief ce bail par des
onze ans la qualité de l'écran par
contre franchement assez bluffante 1
donc l'écran se plie comme ça là vous
avez tout le côté avec vos applications
que navigué en bas qu'on a des petits
raccourcis sur le côté bon ça c'est
vraiment pour la partie logicielle je ne
sais pas ce que c'est ça sa dette pour
lire des trucs ça c'est quoi je tente en
même temps probablement des messages
donc là des raccourcis navigation là
vous avez votre votre android devancé
une surcouche locale mais franchement
c'est plutôt pas mal bon là on est sur
une version développée pour le moment
donc il va falloir encore attendre un
petit peu plus pour quelque chose de
plus abouti là sur le côté sur la
tranche
on a globalement pas grand chose et on
passe de l'autre côté hop voilà là on a
une version avec des infos calendrier
des petits raccourcis
si ça doit être la caméra je pense dans
la petite caméra son côté alors j'ai
quoi photos vidéos portrait voilà moi je
peux venir sous mes joues jusqu'à x 10
hélas ce bouton c'est quoi switch to 2
donc là je mets l'autre côté et là je
passe sur la caméra ria oui d'accord
donc ça c'est vachement drôle ça veut
dire que pour passer de la caméra avant
à la caméra arrière
en fin de compte j'appuie ici hop il me
demande de retourner directement de
l'autre côté je retourne de l'autre côté
je me retrouve directement sur la caméra
avant ça c'est voilà je veux vraiment
posé la question savoir comment ça
pouvait marcher avec ses modules caméra
et au final ça s'est mal donc là on voit
qu'on a un mode qui est assez petit au
final
l'aja puis hop je retrouve de l'autre
côté dans c'est trop cool et là j'ai
quoi même un mode enfant c'est quoi
c'est un mode enfant
je sais pas du tout
[Musique]
ça c'est cool mode nuit mode enfant
homme d'un coup taxe à sous le gros
inconvénient que je verrai la tuque pour
l'instant c'est quand même franchement
assez massif 1 c'est très très épais
c'est très gros je sais pas si ça tient
bien dans une poche à voir ça c'est
vraiment avoir un usage sur le format
atx est un peu dubitatif
le fait que vous avez souvient cette
ouverture là je trouve que c'est pas
forcément ce cas le plus compact
c'est vraiment un produit à mon avis qui
va se développer on est sur le début je
sais pas si c'est leur viol le flex paye
d'orgueil qui va vraiment l'emporter
leur solution est un peu massive avoir à
ce qu'a proposé samsung de son côté avec
son smartphone à écran pliable en
attendant je trouve que c'est assez
intéressant au niveau de voir cette
techno qui avancent qu'il fait pour le
prendre en main comme ça pouvait
manipuler et après ce que me disait la
personne de cyril rool c'est que c'est
du plastique donc c'est complètement
incassable donc si vous avez un écran
oled vous avez du plastique sur dessus
quelque chose de résistants et ça pour
le coup bon pourquoi pas là des gens
voient qu'on a quelques marques derrière
je sais pas ce que c'est si c'est le
plastique a un petit peu un petit peu
morflé à l'arrière vous avez absolument
rien par contre vous voyez vous avez le
nom du smartphone flexspace vous avez
royaume il se doit de boutons de pour
l'allumer bouton de volume on a de la
recharge ici en usb type c'est ok bon
voilà un peu pour cette info aujourd'hui
je vous dis ça on en reparlera d'ici
quelques temps parce que les smartphones
à écrans pliables pour moi c'est quelque
chose de vraiment très très intéressant
et qui va vraiment se démocratiser et
devenir vraiment une vraie révolution
est en tout cas on voit que pour les
usagers ce qui est vraiment intéressant
c'est pour le multimédia pour le gaming
pour vraiment venir regarder vos films
vos séries dessus vous avez quelque
chose qui est très très content cette
solution
je retrouve pas complètement abouti mais
c'est en tout cas un premier joli pas
qui est fait et surtout riols et le
premier à sortir ce produit même si pour
l'instant il n'est pas dispo en france
même si pour l'instant c'est qu'une
version pour développeurs ça reste quand
même vraiment encourageant
parlons un peu de ce smartphone
merci à toute l'équipe du royaume de
m'avoir reçu ces poules ils tombent sur
water os et il est basé sur un android
9.0 ça c'est cool android.spy compte sur
un qualcomm snapdragon de la série 8 pas
plus d'infos là dessus on est d'accord
que tout va bien qu'annoncé jusqu'à 2,8
giguère son maximum alors l'écran ça
c'est intéressant
il a une diagonale une fois ouvert de
7,1 pouces c'est forcément un écran
pliable amoled lorsqu'il ouvert il a une
résolution avec seulement de 1920 par
1440 pixels
c'est marrant parce que vu la taille de
la dalle je me serais attendu à voir une
résolution plus haute bon il faut ouvert
il a un format 4/3 et il a une densité
de pixels de 308 pixels par pouce au
niveau de la ram là deux versions 4 y
aura deux versions 6 giga de ram 8 gigas
de ram et au niveau du stockage s'en
méfient giga octet ou 256 gigaoctets
vous n'êtes pas content et le stockage
et grâce à une carte microsd vous avez
un double module photo à l'avant parce
qu' à l'arrière il ya absolument rien
c'est un peu ça tombe bien avec ce
produit mais je vous expliquais juste
après vous avez un double module photo
16 plus fins médiatiques sel vous avez
une ouverture de f 1.8 ça ça peut être
cool
il faudrait il testé dans d'autres
conditions que celles du cls parce que
ça les lumières partout donc c'est
compliqué de se rencontrent vous avez un
autofocus d'une stabilisation optique de
l'image
vous êtes aussi un flash led bon voilà
ça les infos que j'ai pu glaner sur ma
petite fiche moi ce qui me gêne un petit
peu là dedans c'est que quand on est
quand il est complètement ouvert on a
uniquement qu'un seul même grand écran
auto vous avez absolument rien donc en
fait on a toujours l'écran toujours
accès à l'écran que je prouve que il ya
un dock est très grand et qui du coup
n'est pas utilisée est simple ça qui
peuvent gêner à voir si la solution de
samsung des plus intéressantes galaxy s
galaxy mme x c'est vraiment la question
je veux pas parce que ce que je me dis
c'est qu'effectivement votre smartphone
une fois ouvert vous ayez un grand écran
ça c'est clair c'est la base
dans tous les cas ça marche très bien la
différence hockey avec le choix de
samsung c'est que lorsque vous refermez
j'avais les écrans de chaque côté je
trouve qu'il a un côté qui vient
d'intégrer d'autres un peu moins joli je
crois pas l'intégrer de switcher d'un
côté et de l'autre parce que la partie
vous avez module photo c'est forcément
un écran qu un peu plus réduit je vois
pas l'intérêt direct sur celui là dit
elle son lot pas là puisque ça perd un
peu de son sens parce que je trouve plus
intéressant avoir effectivement lors de
la prise en main avec la solution de sa
mission c'est à dire que une fois pliée
et les deux écrans sont trouvés
confirmés et vous avez un petit écran de
4 pouces et demi et me semble-t-il en
façade la preuve que vous avez accès à
des notifications à quelques messages un
peu rapide des sms mais le grand écran
est complètement pris un verre et
d'ailleurs du coup car abonnés
écran la série voilà les deux gros
points de différence à voir également je
pense que la charnière est assez épaisse
après j'adore vraiment l'effort qui fut
j'adore vraiment là des clients trouve
que c'est vraiment l'avenir du smart
phone des écrans tourisme grand pourquoi
parce qu'on va qu'on regarde plus la
télé que j'étais dans le multimédia est
devenue aujourd'hui un des premiers
usages du smartphone au delà de l'appel
du sms est probablement gmail et le
multimédia c'est vraiment sérieux juste
après donc c'est un vrai sens pur du
gaming pour regarder d'une équipe ex des
études pour moi c'est un vrai sens c'est
un vrai basculement la télé à terme va
disparaître peut être existé avec des
écrans pliables était vraiment
disparaître de nos pièces de vie
principal et va être remplacé à la
différents écrans avec sur un
réfrigérateur sur une mode pourquoi pas
comme samsung a pu présenter dans votre
poche ou pourquoi pas une télé avec un
écran qui s'enroulent enfin ça peut
avoir un vrai sens c'est le vrai début
d'une nouvelle ère d'une nouvelle
révolution et c'est vraiment intéressant
dans ses bottes big man vous ce que vous
en pensez en commentaire est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ce que je viens de
dire est ce que
cette solution explique comme ça et
est-ce que se produit une fois qu'il
sera vraiment très vite est finie
développé pour y ait succombé et vous
pourriez l'acheter une smartphones à
écran pliable
c'est vraiment je dirais leterrier gaza
pour faire parler d'eux enfin qui
fabrique beaucoup d'écrans désintègre
elle des écrans sur l'espèce de chaque
fois qu'un autre forme voulait bosser
sur des t-shirts mont sainte marie paule
c'est plus simple pour rigoler c'est
déjà ce effectivement qui vont se
développer dans les années à venir
mais en plus de ça et ce qui est
vraiment hyper intéressante en train de
développer une solution pour mettre des
grands écrans dans votre voiture écran
qu'il ya vraiment venir s'intégrer
alors l'idée effectivement c'est d'avoir
des commandes directement su comme jour
et d'en inventer le vécu et en plus de
ça qui va intégrer du multimédia pouvoir
regarder un film lorsque vous êtes dans
des embouteillages et vous avancez à
deux à l'heure où monsieur vraiment je
dirais bloqués est ce que j aime dire à
la personne assure golfe qui à mon avis
ça en france c'est mort de che nord ça
n'arrivera jamais simplement parce que
ça sera jamais autorisé par le
gouvernement en terme de sécurité
classiques l'hôtel août en arrière
j'imagine mal ce soir autorisant les ans
même si vous avancez pas de regarder un
film en même temps à mon avis ça c'est
très très complet pour intégrer dans les
constructeurs français ne jugez pas
d'ailleurs ces êtres hors de france et
dites-moi ce que c'est quelque chose qui
vous pensent en tout cas pour arriver
dans votre pays sans plus et ska et rios
et vous êtes un deuxième écran
directement au niveau de votre volant
vous avez des ragots si vous avez
d'autres choses qui s'affichent
directement au niveau du enfin c'est
vraiment intéressant puisque tout ce que
ça montre c'est un vrai déplacement
c'était la télé qui était maître le roi
de l'écran d'ordinateur sont arrivés
après que ça se développe de plus en
plus les smartphones et aujourd'hui
alors que l'écran était l'apanage de la
télévision c'est bien complètement
inverse la télé pas disparaître vraiment
en train de se transformer et les écrans
deviennent de plus en plus omniprésent
il y en a dans les voitures va y avoir
deux joueurs évoluent vers plus de
choses dans les années à venir
là par exemple vous avez typiquement un
écran pliable qui est complètement
intégrée sur une enceinte c'est
exactement la même chose là dessus alors
vous avez un cs innovation awards vous
avez un écran qui fait complètement le
tour de votre enceinte et c'est vrai que
ça rajoute vraiment c'est assez sympa
pour avoir aussi des écrans pliables sur
la décoration intérieure vous l'avez
également comme je disais sur d'ouvert
ebola typiquement vous avez un sac à
main avec un écran pliable dessus c'est
aussi assez impressionnant regardez ça
là vous avez un haut-de-forme avec un
écran pliable toujours chez orioles vous
avez ensuite le t-shirt ciment des
écrans pliables absolument de partout
schiergen un robot avec un écran tactile
l'écran est pliée aussi là on le voit de
cette manière là ok fans de will filles
c'est pour ça que ça marche pas mais en
tout cas bon ça c'est rigolo
en fait ce qu'on voit ici et ce qui est
super intéressant
c'est leur stand revoir mais ce qui est
vraiment très intéressant c'est le
positionnement des écrans dans notre
quotidien ou inscrire dans notre culture
de notre avenir c'est aux écrans à
s'adapter aux objets et c'est pas aux
objets d'art et et aux écrans donc le
fait d'avoir des crampes ryad
c'est vraiment très intéressant voilà je
crois ce que vous en pensez marc et tout
ça en commentaire sais pas si vous vous
souvenez dernière j'avais fait une vidéo
justement s'envole quant à l'or il
n'avait pas de bras il avec des gens par
contre il me sentais super bien les
escaliers c'était vraiment très
impressionnant et là il prend une forme
un peu plus humanoïdes avec ce qui
ressemble à une tête priori des bras
enfin voilà ward et les fonctions
beaucoup plus avancé en tout cas si vous
souvenez partir de la vidéo du seul
domaine dernière parce que la fonction
de marche était vraiment impressionnante
qui descendent des escaliers
il peut jouer au ballon c'est pas
complètement fini en tout cas c'est
vraiment hyper impressionnant voiture
n'était qu'un petit peu what the fuck là
vous avez un drone volant qui peut
inclure un humain dessus donc ça je me
demande ce que ça donne et surtout en
terme d'expérience ça doit être
complètement fou ça c'est impressionnant
j'avais une reconnaissance des gens des
formes ça les modélistes complètement ya
un côté un peu big brother là-dedans
l'enchère déjà vu l'année dernière vous
avez une vraie reconnaissance de visage
le truc est assez flippant ça dépend
vraiment des usages de ce qu'on peut en
faire
en tout cas pour faire de la
surveillance ou la reconnaissance du bon
et à côté quand même hyper flippant ça
c'est impressionnant parce qu'avec la
main sans aucun contact sans aucun
capteur l'écran est complètement piloter
c'est assez cool landais sur le stand de
vos ouailles en tout cas c'est
intéressant vous avez plein de petites
figurines avec des visages vous en avez
qui tourne autres qui restent à tiques
vous avez une espèce de petite caméra
qui filme là
et là sur l'écran ça vous fait de la
détection de visages et ça vaut calculer
exactement le nombre de visages qui a un
instant t alors pareils dans les
problématiques de sécurité smartcity ça
peut avoir un sens ça reste quand même
malgré tout un peu flippant mais en tout
cas on voit qu'on est vraiment là sur la
la gestion de la ville du futur
en termes de sécurité en termes de
reconnaissance des personnes
il y aussi un côté assez intéressant
[Musique]
oui en
correa bout ce week-end
hello you are some traditionnel brink's
yama poli la police des polices à la
foule a défilé au caire comme inch nails
on avait l'habitude de les reconnaître
[Musique]
au caveau tête
zhao médicaux liens vers les yo yo avec
les eaux du canal et du blick leur nez
sur le stand de la corée on lui dit un
petit peu la forêt enfin du tourisme on
peut le dire en face il ya plein
start-up coréenne ça a l'air assez
intéressant alors on parle beaucoup les
stars 2 française et pourquoi pas avoir
un peu ce qui se passe du côté de l'asie
focus sur la corée du sud on va regarder
un peu à mon avis alors ça c'est rigolo
en une solution de réalité virtuelle on
a le casque elle effectivement elle voit
des choses et puis on est en plus
derrière des manettes des contrôleurs
pour vraiment aller plus loin au niveau
la sensation de verre et là en fin de
compte elle est en train de conduire
c'est quoi bein l'espèce de tractopelle
pour l'attitude mans c'était pascal plus
fun comme ça que tractopelle mais c'est
assez marrant pour rien on est sur des
lunettes qui permet de faire de la
rééducation pour vos yeux pour vraiment
mesurer le niveau de stress de vos yeux
voir un petit peu où vous en êtes et
pour vous permettre complètement en
regardant des vidéos en adaptant la
llorona les eaux là qu'elles sont un
casque qui est très très beau comme ça
ça permet vraiment de faire la
rééducation ça permet de faire du
bien-être pour vos yeux récupérer se
soigner c'est beau c'est pratiquants
farthouat c'est très pratique
non c'est plutôt cool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui je
vous invite à me dire ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire du nouveau
smartphone à écran pliable le flex paye
du royaume et je vous invite aussi à
voir les autres vidéos du ce est ce
parce que franchement il ya pleins sont
intéressants plein de choses rigolotes
comme ça on reste ensemble d'ici là
soyez sages à demain pour les soins de
soutien
non